along the Western Balkans hood we saw
refugees wading through freezing rivers
soon this will be snow and ice we need
to slow down the uncontrolled flow of
people I have to say no registration no
whites while we should acknowledge and
support the contribution of Turkey
Jordan and Lebanon we should also be
asking when will the rich Arab countries
and the USA step up the first thing to
do that is the European border and Coast
Guard so that we can regain control over
our borders that doesn't mean that we
have to create a fortress Europe it's
quite astonished that we had to
undertake a huge effort to convince some
of our member states that again shows
that European Union is not in a good
shape
you leave Mystic Valley Shaitan this
Ebert's openly nuts and I starts this
Knutson an ego is mooses yeah here cited
as it is a Roopa phone ferret run from
leap in the sixth Watts drift want is
amended a target wasn't kind of explicit
so Sunday bring for about democratic
rights we've seen four countries let I
guess for the strongest Hungary making
it clear they want no part of EU migrant
quotas I will define themselves crushed
through au trickery and made to accept
the very thing that they'd said no to it
has the potential even to destroy
achievements such as border free travel
between Schengen countries what is even
more dangerous it has the potential to
create tectonic changes in the European
political landscape plot surname in
monitamon town names in up net sign
stop in Midtown
NASA conference the president in his mob
the Asafa of pies for Lyon Master an in
Saudi Arabian blogger raif Badawi
each father I am it including from Saudi
Arabia now Abu Dhabi inferred cyclists
to begin Erdogan in tried solace in the
middle in rice and vegan even come coast
is the roman catherine hawley dos dez de
junio de dos mil diecisiete con este
acuerdo europa Sarah la única razón del
mundo que guarantees a median tele UN
internet abierto Alana neutral edad de
la Rionda situation so a co-producer
vocal is animal more more mmm decision
on pretty cat woven Polly contain the
nanoparticles so Cali consummate a
no-reserve oaken and occasion Appa la
puerta logo sans wasn't a on whisker
deserve our new president the Parliament
open nap anchor walk the pasilla Russia
need opt need ot